While the question of hamsters powering homes
may seem a bit farcical, it should be noted
that at one point humans did specifically
breed a certain type of dog for the sole purpose
of it just walking along at a steady pace
on a giant wheel…
(See our article The Curious Tale of Turnspit
Dogs.)
Now, to begin with, according to the U.S.
Energy Information Administration (EIA), the
average American household uses about 901
kWh per month, which for the sake of simplicity
we’re going to round down to 900 kWh.
A single kWh is equal to 3.6 Megajoules.
This means in any given month, an average
American household uses about 3,240 Megajoules
of energy.
In a given year, that would be about 38,880
Megajoules.
The amount of power produced by your typical
hamster running as fast as it can on its little
wheel is understandably much more difficult
to nail down.
However, it appears that a properly motivated
little ball of fluff can reliably produce
somewhere in the ballpark of 0.5 joules per
second while running.
Now the number of seconds in a year is approximately
31,540,000 (give or take depending on leap
year and the like).
Thus, a hamster with infinite stamina and
no need to sleep could produce about 15,770,000
joules or 15.77 Megajoules per year.
This means it would take approximately 2,465
such hamsters to provide the needed electricity
to power a typical American home for a year.
Of course, hamsters with infinite stamina
and with no need to sleep do not exist, so
what about using real hamsters?
It’s estimated that a typical hamster will
spend about 5% of their time exercising.
Thus, instead of around 15.77 Megajoules per
year, we can reasonably expect about 0.8 Megajoules
per year per hamster, unless you wanted to
selectively breed some super hamster or something,
FOR SCIENCE, which we could totally get behind.
But barring that, we’ll go with the currently
existing real world variety.
Thus, it would take in the ballpark of 486,000
hamsters running on wheels connected to generators
to produce enough electricity for an average
American home for a year.
And for further reference, given the 3 year
lifespan of a typical hamster kept in captivity,
to power a home for the average amount of
time a typical homeowner lives in it (13 years
according to National Association of Home
Builders), you’d need well over 2.1 million
hamsters, with a little excess to account
for baby and elderly hamsters not pulling
their own weight.
Now to the second part of the question- would
hamster power be cheaper than coal power?
A typical hamster costs anywhere between $4
and $20 dollars, depending on the pet store
you buy it from, the breed and coloration.
Thus, you’d be looking at spending around
$10 million over that 13 years just on the
cost of hamster alone, even at the $4 price.
However, given you’d have more than enough
hamsters around to breed your own after some
first starter batch, we’re prepared to say
that the price of acquiring your hamster stock
wouldn’t actually be anywhere close to that
$10 million figure.
For reference, a female hamster can breed
at a rate of about 5 baby hamsters, give or
take, every 3 weeks or so, and then ready
to go again, sometimes within just 24 hours
of giving birth.
Further, as with many species and politicians,
the males are both willing and able to get
it on even multiple times per day with multiple
partners if the females will let them.
On top of that, hamsters become sexually mature
at around 4-6 weeks.
So if you started with just 1000 hamsters,
with a large percentage female, purchased
at a bulk discount of, say, a dollar or two
a hamster, you could feasible very cheaply
ramp up to the needed half million or so hamsters
with controlled breeding in under 6 months.
But we’re not done because there are a lot
of ancillary expenses here.
To begin with, all of those hamsters need
cages- an additional expense of around $30
dollars per hamster cage.
If you wanted to have one hamster per cage,
you’ll need about 500,000 cages or so- a
steal at just $15 million dollars.
Now, you could put multiple hamsters in a
cage (assuming you aren’t using a breed
like the common Syrian hamster that cannot
be kept together lest they murder each other).
But if you did this, you’d definitely want
to put in place some sort of breeding control
unless you had in mind to sell excess hamsters
for profit.
But either way, according to the Humane Society,
hamsters need about two square feet of cage
per hamster for a happy little life- and as
we all know, a happy worker is a good worker.
So doubling up or more would just mean bigger
cages and thus the cost benefit might not
really be all that much unless you’re just
a cruel person caring only for electricity
to power your iPhone and not for any creatures
you have to step on to get it.
(#Hamsterlivesmatter)
The real savings here with regard to cages
might simply just be in economy of scale.
If you called up a hamster cage making company
and said you wanted to place an order for
500,000 hamster cages, we’re pretty sure
that after doing a little happy dance, they’d
be willing to cut the price down pretty markedly.
How much is impossible to say, of course,
as no hamster cage maker we could find lists
the type of discount they’d give on an order
of 500,000 hamster cages.
However, based on what we found from large
scale hamster cage maker’s wholesale bulk
pricing (when purchasing hundreds of units
at a time), it would seem you can get an adequately
sized hamster cage setup for $3-$5 per unit,
cutting the price for cages down to roughly
$2 million.
But wait, there’s more.
You’ll also need food for the hamsters.
A 2lb bag of hamster food can last around
a month and will cost you about $5 if bought
in bulk.
(Or, at least, given current bulk prices of
pre-packaged hamster food grain mixes.)
This means that feeding about a half million
hamsters will cost about $30 million per year.
Now normally we might say that some government
subsidies might kick in here similar to what
coal power enjoys, but in this case probably
not.
You see, about 30% of the electricity generated
in the U.S. comes from coal power.
Thus, if the power companies all decided to
switch to hamster power from coal, this would
result in a required grain mix food supply
of about 400 trillion pounds per year for
the approximately 16 trillion hamsters needed.
Unfortunately, this eclipses the annual world-wide
production of grain which currently sits at
about 6 trillion pounds per year.
So we’re going to go ahead and assume given
it would only be possible for a very small
percentage of the population to benefit from
hamster power and that it wouldn’t ever
scale beyond that, until Big Hamster inevitably
starts to line the pockets of politicians,
no such subsidies will exist.
That said, on the one-house scale, we’ll
go ahead and allow for a pretty substantial
discount given the massive bulk orders one
would be placing annually here.
And from a little googling around on what
granaries in the U.S. tend to sell various
grains for by the ton, it would seem the actual
price of the hamster food annually would be
about $1 million per year, give or take a
few hundred thousand dollars.
Of course, hamsters running on a wheel won’t
do you much good unless there is some sort
of electricity generating device hooked up
to them.
So what will that cost?
At the high end, electric motors that can
generate 0.5 joules per second each at around
a ballpark RPM rate needed here would run
in the range of $3 million without bulk discounting.
Unfortunately we were not able to find a supplier
that would give us a quote for what a half
a million of such motors would cost with discounting
applied.
But from much smaller scale bulk discounts
we did observe, we’re willing to bet one
could probably cut the price in half.
So we’ll just go ahead and estimate those
little motors would cost around $1.5 million…
Work with us here people.
But we’re not done.
Your hamster power plant will take up a significant
amount of floor space.
If you take into account the size of a small
cage and the accompanying food stores and
aren’t being Hitler to the Hamsters, this
would maximally take around a million square
feet of warehouse space.
However, this can be substantially reduced
via stacking the cages up as far as their
structural integrity could take.
For the sake of argument, let’s say you
stacked the cages 10 high and spaced the rows
about two feet apart for access.
Now, the exact number of rows needed would
depend partially on the design of cages and
warehouse layout, but we’ll ballpark it
and say you’d need roughly 300 rows, meaning
a warehouse roughly 600 ft by 320 ft or around
192,000 square feet of space.
Adding in space for food storage and the like,
and 200,000 square feet (about 450 feet by
450 feet) seems like a reasonable estimate.
Now, the co-author of this piece, Karl Smallwood
of FactFiend fame, actually went ahead and
contacted a real estate agent leasing a similarly
size warehouse as would be needed here and
was informed that for a long term rental the
price could be negotiated down.
But unfortunately he was rebuffed when they
asked what we’d be using the space for and
he started talking about hamsters.
So, bottom line, we never got an official
estimate of how much the price on the space
could be negotiated down too.
Thus, instead we went with the average rental
cost of large warehouse space per square foot
in the U.S. which is about $4.80.
This would create an additional cost of $960,000
every year.
Now, a typical hamster can poop quite a bit,
but we had a really hard time tracking down
a figure on exact daily pooping rates of hamsters.
However, after observing a friend’s hamster
for an hour and spending some time on hamster-owner
message boards, we concluded that they probably
poop about 20 times a day, give or take.
Multiplying this by the amount of hamsters
you, our fictitious burgeoning mad genius
will own, this means you’ll have to deal
with about 10 million tiny hamster turds per
day.
Estimating that each adorable little piece
of fecal matter weighs about a gram, you’ll
have to somehow clean up 10,000 kilos of poop
every day- the cost of which varies depending
on how you plan on disposing of it.
However, we’re prepared to write off the
cost of disposal completely given the potential
here to make the poop, composted with the
soiled wood shavings, a money maker if used
for fertilizer or things of this nature.
And, in fact, using biogas recovery systems
similar to ones developed for generating electricity
via cow-poop, there’s even potential for
some electricity generation this way to offset
the cost before moving on to the fertilizer
stage.
So, again, we’re going to go ahead and summarily
call the poop and wood shaving disposal cost
a wash.
Rounding out the potential major costs includes
things like climate control, wood shavings
for flooring for your little hamster army,
water, and caretakers.
We’re prepared to think you could automate
the feeding and watering easily and cheaply
enough (at least relative to the other costs),
and thus wouldn’t actually need that terribly
many workers excepting to clean the cages.
As for this, it would appear based on a surprising
number of forum posts around the interwebs
discussing the length of time it takes to
clean a hamster cage, that a laymen would
be looking at about 20 minutes per complete
cleaning done weekly and only a few minutes
for spot cleaning done daily.
However, we’re guessing a pro-cleaner could
cut those times at least in half and one could
probably skip the spot cleaning without too
negatively impacting the hamsters.
Thus, you’d require roughly 350,000 man
hours per month to keep the cages clean, likely
making up the majority of cost of labor here.
This would be a little over 2,000 or so full
time workers operating the facility.
As this is pretty low skilled work, we’re
going to assign the average salary here to
be equivalent to the average McDonald’s
worker, and thus bringing your labor cost
to around $40 million per year…
Of course, you could always save money here
by employing for free an army of children
who claim they want a hamster and are willing
to take care of it if given one.
Or, given the pretty steep price tag for non-child
labor, we’re pretty confident you could
just invest some money into largely automating
the cleaning process as this seems to be an
easily solvable problem that no one has yet
addressed owing to kids needing to learn responsibility.
But how much the upfront cost would be on
cage modifications and the like to automate
the process is impossible to estimate even
with the types of large error bars we’re
already dealing with, so we’ll leave that
estimate to you, dear reader.
Going back to the daily water requirements,
this would only be in the realm of 10,000
liters per day (2600 gallons).
Thus, this cost is going to be negligible
given the average cost of water in the U.S.
per gallon from a utility is only about $1.50
per 1000 gallons.
Though, maybe don’t set up your operation
in Southern California…
As for the wood shavings, as noted, these
need replaced roughly once a week to keep
a healthy, happy hamster, and would maximally
cost about $34 million per year.
However, upon searching, we found a company
that sells baled wood shavings by the semi-truck
load of the grade and type needed for a cost
of approximately 1/50th of the price of bulk
hamster bed shavings found at pet stores.
This brings the price down to only around
$600,000 per year.
Moving on to climate control, this would vary
based on climate, but in general most types
of hamster, despite being desert animals by
nature, tend to prefer temperatures in the
range of 65-75 degrees Fahrenheit or 18-24
degrees Celsius, similar to humans.
So in order to avoid having to use more energy
than the hamsters are generating to climate
control the facility, you’d probably want
to go ahead and pick a pretty mild to cool
climate area for your home and hamster power
farm.
You see, it turns out your half a million
hamsters generate quite a bit of heat, so
with decent insulation and a controllable
heat exchanger system for the warehouse to
get fresh air coming in while regulating temperature
appropriately, you should have very little
trouble keeping the warehouse warm enough
in winter.
You can even use some of this warm air to
directly heat your house, cutting out the
middle man, assuming you want your house to
smell like a mix of hamster, urine, pine,
and feces.
On the other end, so long as you lived in
a region with mild summers and you had ability
to open the warehouse up to significant natural
air circulation, the summers shouldn’t cost
you much of anything either.
Pick the wrong climate, however, and this
would be a very different story.
For your reference here, the average cost
of heating or cooling a warehouse space in
the U.S. is approximately 30 cents per square
foot per year, which would put the hamster
power plant at around $60,000 per year for
climate control.
This finally brings us to wiring.
Luckily you wouldn’t need very thick wiring
to carry the kind of currents needed here
to some central power management unit.
And even with the vast length needed, with
the bulk discounting numbers we’re seeing,
this cost would be negligible compared to
the cost of the other major factors, at under
$50,000.
While there certainly would be other costs
associated with rigging up such a setup, including
battery storage, power regulators, etc., given
the cost of the most expensive bits, we can
safely assume they likewise wouldn’t affect
the overall ballpark figure that much when
talking about powering a single home.
Thus, to sum up the cost of enough hamster
power to run one home, with the aforementioned
bulk discounting applied and some reasonable
sized error bars, it would appear we’re
looking at around $6 million the first year
(including setup costs) and roughly $2.5-$3
million every year thereafter, plus cost of
labor which, depending on the level of automation
you come up with and/or free child labor,
would likely range from a few million dollars
per year up to around $40 million.
So what does coal power cost?
According to Lazard’s Levelized Cost of
Energy Analysis, unsubsidized coal power used
to power one average American home for a year
would cost approximately $1,200, though it’s
noted they don’t take into account external
environmental and health impact costs and
the like- simply attempting to strip away
more direct subsidies.
But either way, very unfortunately, even if
you wanted to create a breed of Lance Armstrong-esk
hamsters (though maybe with both balls to
maximize virility, but otherwise do go ahead
and pump them full of steroids), then go the
insanely inhumane route to cut down on infrastructure
costs and force long running times, and then
have Big Hamster push hard for government
subsidies, coal power’s still going to win
this one hands down- humorously probably even
on environmental impact, all things considered.
Researchers in 2009 actually found a way of
creating electricity from hamsters, outfitting
them with tiny jackets that converted their
every movement they made into usable AC energy.
Utilising flexible nanowires made of zinc
oxide that produce electricity every time
they are flexed, bent or otherwise moved,
the small jackets allowed a single hamster
to produce about 1 twentieth the energy released
by a AA battery while running.
The idea is to eventually use this technology
to produce clothes that charge our phones
or other technology such as medical devices
during ordinary movement.